So let's now look at what happens when in the
case of strong consistency. In strong consistency, you're always guaranteed
to get the data that has returned from a put
operation towards the data store API. So when the query
is received by the data story API, it will see
that there are pending updates for the data that you
are querying for. It will then wait and then get
the data once the datastore backend has finished. And then
it returns that result. That's why
it's called strong consistency. The result from
queries will always be consistent with put
operations performed earlier toward the datastore API.
So which is better, eventual consistency
or strong consistency? Well that depends on
your application. Let's look at two examples.
The first one Posting a Blog Comment.
In this case eventual consistency's probably best to
use. This is because to update, it probably
does not need to be immediate. And there
is no operation dependency, in other words there are
no subsequent operations that relies on data being
completely up to date. What about this one? An
atm money withdrawal. Well that's certainly candidate for
strong consistency because even though you may not like
it, the new balance should be reflected immediately and
there may be operation dependency. For example, there may
be purchases coming in on that account that depends
on an up to date balance. You may now
say, so why don't I use strong consistency all
the time? Well, remember the use case. Strong consistency
causes a lot of wait and locks in your
application. So if you want to build applications that scale.
You should use eventual consistency as often as
possible. Luckily, datastore supports both of these models.
You can use the default fast and scalable
eventual consistency when required. And when you need
to ensure strong consistency, that is also supported.
Let's see how, because it's quite simple. You
enforce strong consistency when you have an ancestor
relationship and your query use filter by this ancestor.
If those two conditions are met all children
will be queried using strong consistency, in all other
cases data will be retrieved using eventual consistency. As
we already discussed, strong consistency has a performance and
scalability penalty compared to eventual consistency. So you
need to look at your application to determine the
best option for every query situation. All right, enough
theory for now. Time for a quiz. Good luck.